juste avant de rentrer dans la cage et
sa montée sur le stand
il faut montrer je commence à te calmer
un peu
quand ça commence de combat appelé
première coup c'est bon t'es dedans plus
triste oublier ces particules du
combattu en france au début et après à
travers l'europe partout un peu je suis
allé jusqu au moyen orient en afrique le
maroc l'asie
l'avaient fait ils essaient de diviser
justement présenté moi
un père est un plus je suis la réforme
juste
surtout aujourd'hui le chose
partie intégrale du mma les
organisateurs le promoteur et le public
qui veut voir du show diverti on doit un
peu acteur en même temps du coup il y en
a naturellement ils savent jouer un rôle
mais à nice a pas l'faire du coup ça se
voit trop et moi dans tout ça j'essaie
de rester moi même parce que moi je pas
très bon accueil
je sais que marseille y est un peu fou
il fait des fois du goût il fait des
frappes un peu aléatoire et au soleil un
peu basique comme stratégie est simple
qu'aujourd'hui rendu j'ai fait mon style
et monstres ça consiste à
si je peux l'amener au sujet la mousson
ces papillons mais elle ne peut plus
vous pouvez trouver sur son volet en
s'échauffant qui lance étiez que je peux
faire et on commence à monter la
température à petit
il
c'est louche un peu bizarre mais elio
verde
beaucoup de points voir comment son
métal jaune et ses qualités son métal
fort
10 je me dis juste ok oui j'ai peur
j'avoue j'accepte déjà dans ma tête but
de faire ça dans facile beaucoup de
choses à vous et à soi même et ses peurs
s'apprécient c'est comme si un fardeau
qui tangue de toile
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
déjà les 15 premières
des moutons
m
après ça le toit tout peut arriver
aujourd'hui j'y bien-être du mois mais
on s'en fout
j'ai tout appris
merci à wagner pour les techniques voilà
c'est faisable mon père
n'a pas besoin de beaucoup de monde
autour de toi il te suffit une deux
trois personnes qui sont bien pour ceux
que le bien du club qui ont vraiment et
du rêve leur coeur sa facilité beaucoup
de choses